right when I'm this is not a corona
cough this is a marijuana crop I think I
haven't been tested get in there any
problem let's just go oh [ __ ] whiskey
son we're gonna whisk you brains that
Blanton sauce that's great so we were
all chillin at home under quarantine not
really quarantine LA is not in the
quarantine yet but I hear word I hear
word that California and Washington
State are gonna get the lockdown
treatment for two weeks I don't know man
I don't know I planned at home I plan
for a month I planned for a month of
food yeah me too I just stocked up like
a dick I have tons of meat though I'm a
carnivore it to the end of the year
legitimately that's what I did drink
Creek water I got a [ __ ] filter I got
a pump filter the kids I did the hampers
yeah they love it man just everybody can
be Carnival they'll just have to I don't
think that's it's gonna come to that I
really don't I think I think if you look
at the numbers like this is not a good
cold
it's a dangerous one it's a dangerous
one because it kills the [ __ ] out of all
people but so does a bad flu and it's
it's different than a bad flu in in some
people's accounts in that it's causing
some serious damage what do you got
there Jamie oh it's it causes damage to
lungs damage you hear it on both ends
though you know like you hear one expert
says it's how terrible it's gonna be
here another expert goes it's actually
go about your life but I'll just wash
your hands because just go about your
life though you hear both ends of it
there's a good article on manic there's
a good article in Atlantic about it and
the article in the Atlantic was
basically saying we're all gonna get it
and one of the reasons why this is a
really tricky one is that the symptoms
don't show up for a while yeah so you
could be contagious for a long time it
doesn't kill people quick see the thing
about that avian flu that they put the
kibosh - that was a really deadly one
about 60% of the people that got it so
China acted immediately - killed
something like a million five hundred
thousand chickens it's all in this
article and they just shut everything
down they're like this is x2 this is
something that's gonna [ __ ] kill half
the population like legitimately kill
after popular there's Oregon Washington
Post that gets like a bunch of experts
and kind of what the things they agree
on about the corona virus and
you read that makes you feel better yeah
now granted a lot of people day a lot of
it is up in the air they don't know what
scares me is what's going on in France
because Jake Tapper just tweeted that
some large number more than 50% of the
cases that are serious like
hospitalization are people that are
under 60 which is very unusual because
the other people in other places that we
they're they're reporting that it's
mostly old vulnerable or people with
underlying health conditions we do mean
says yeah weak immune systems people
with high blood pressure but you know
you really stop and look at the numbers
of just the flu and this is supposed to
be way worse than the flu but if you
look at the numbers for the flu the flu
kills a fuckload appears a [ __ ]
thank you 50,000 in world just in the
United States cheers I gotta take a sip
yeah Cheers